this is a production of cornell
university
today i'm going to talk about
crop diversification practices for
resilience and
what really motivated me to do this work
i for several decades
there's been a call for ag systems to
become
less dependent on synthetic external
inputs than more recently there's been
a um a growing awareness that climate
change is going to really affect
ag production systems and so
i want to positively contribute
by using ecology to make an argument for
crop diversification practices
and show how these practices help
enhance
the resilience of farms in the face of
extreme
weather events and so
crop diversification is it it's a big
thing
it's not a silver bullet and perhaps
it's more i have to think about it as a
golden
lasso and so like this
lasso we're gonna start broad and then
get
narrower as we go through the
presentation
and the the dissertation itself spans
several
lines of inquiry um
and draws extras from qualitative and
quantitative
methods and so in some places i
interview farmers
others i perform field experiments
[Music]
and some of the the guiding questions
are
how do we achieve crop diversification
and a break out of the question is like
what is
diversification uh why is it beneficial
what are we working with what does that
system look like
um you know like
how how do we assess diversification and
then how do we
improve crop diversification and so
these guiding questions will be on the
above panels and and we'll frame the
talk
and so what is it so crop
diversification all my work
in the context of northeastern greece
this is a really ideal setting
because it's rain fed agriculture so
we're not
water limited like a lot of people are
uh out west and the other thing is is
that there's this
integration with animals dairies not
have dairy cows and so
this opens up the door to some more
practices
some of those practices include having
pastures so grazing whatever your
imagery of a bucolic scene is where an
animal is out on the field
perennial forages so forages um
that are grown for multiple years and
then
mowed uh several times intercropping
those perennials so growing multiple
species together and then for
annual production double cropping which
is the harvest of two
annuals a year cover cropping you have
your
cash crop but then you're also planting
their crops to kind of
rebuild uh your ag system
and then intercropping annuals so
the mixture of multiple species in
annuals and so
um there's this ever present ticking
uh in the background of climate change
in the northeast
and uh well climate change everywhere in
the northeast
uh since 1958
there's been a 71 increase
in the frequency of extreme weather
events so
99th percentile and the amount in those
precipitation events has
increased every year in addition to
those
annual temperatures and short and medium
term
droughts are projected to increase all
this to say is
this creates difficulties to produce
sufficient on farm feed
and so here's the here's a quote from
one of my
farmer interviews who had experienced an
extreme
weather event he said our banker
said all the farms in this area
are hundreds of thousands of dollars
behind because of those heavy rains
because they've suffered yield loss
versus the other side of the county
so she could actually pinpoint it on the
map
and they're very localized events
and if you think about farms you say
well no
maybe you can get away you get you can
carry through with one extreme weather
event
what if that's happening every year or
every other year
so this is this is what i think of when
i
when i want resilience i'm speaking
about social
ecological resilience so considering
humans and nature together human gender
managing these agro ecosystems and these
agroecosystems
then provide things for us and so when i
think about resilience i really like
this basins of attraction model
that that walker has where he
he breaks it down to three components
how much
stress can your ag system
absorb right how deep is it how much
flexibility and opportunity is there
in the system so how much latitude do
you have
and then that precarity how close is it
from
flipping to a different state an
unproductive state
and i really want to stay in in these
rounds
this one it it scares me um
so when i think about crop
diversification and why is it beneficial
it's because it increases both the
spatial
and the temporal variance of a landscape
so you have a simplified landscape
and then you have one that has more
variety to it
over time you know with rotations you
can see that that variety
is a compounding
and one of the reasons or
you know the benefits from crop
diversity are derived from these
mechanisms and
what this is is that species have traits
and
they perform uh certain functions right
the
traits give them the ability to do
certain things
we we can think of when you have
multiple species together perhaps they
can access
resources differently perhaps they can
feel
facilitate the availability of resources
to another species and then the other
benefit is stability so species
also have different responses to the
environment
and because of those different responses
your whatever the conditions are it's
going to have a stabilizing
effect in addition to this there's
diversity of practice
so if you're managing for different
components labor needs are more
distributed they're not coming all at
once and also
there's a potential for a diversity of
markets so you're distributing the risk
of market
volatility sort of managing that
top-down
uh risk
so the the next part is thinking about
the social
ecological system as a whole so we
talked about resilience
and then just to map out this system
i'm i'm one of those people who like to
know
all these different components of like
how do these fit together
so when i think about a social
ecological system for
farms i think about farms at this
central
focal level and they're managing fields
and this is where crop diversification
practices
occur but farms are also embedded in
socio-technical configuration
these are the large societal regulatory
institutions that sort of shape the
firm's
behavior so to dig into this a little
bit more
um i want to fill out this map
and so in the field we have
ecosystem services so we can think of
that happening down here
and then at the firm level there's a
physical space
right that farm looks like something
what kind of soil it has etc
and then uh farmers manage
this physical space
and then farmers themselves are guided
in their management by their worldview
by their values
their their beliefs their motivations
and so then as i said farms are embedded
in a socio-technical
configuration what this breaks down to
is a socio-technical
system and i'll give you an example
because that's a complicated word
what this is is when you consider social
and technical elements together
so if i were to manage my weeds
with an herbicide then
i would need a sprayer right i would
need a specific technology specific
piece of equipment
and i also need information about those
herbicides
versus if i was doing weed management
with tillage then i would
need different kinds of equipment and
different kinds of information
so with the socio-technical regime these
are just
the the rules so policies
um regulations but also
norms so hard rules and soft rules
and these things are all being managed
by a network
of actors and they interact with each
other
yes so
then the question becomes who are we
working with
who uh exists in this system and so i
wanted to find out more
about dairy farmers so i interviewed 25
dairy farmers in western uh
new york which is an innovative dairy
region
and about half of those farmers were
organic
meaning they had to follow they were
organic certified so they had to
follow organic certification regulations
which say that you have to have animals
on pasture
for 120 days of the year and
that 30 of the dry matter feed
must come from pasture
but also there's a minimum amount of
crop complexity and so
i asked farmers you know i asked them
about
their farm operations and what they look
like
so kind of the tech technology part you
know how they
managed and then uh what they thought
about certain things
and what struck them and then to get at
this sociotechnical
configuration i asked about information
sources farmers turned to you for land
management practices
and then for the field level i asked
about their extent
of diversification practices so trying
to fill out this
this map and so with regard to the
information
sources farmers access i
given this list of sources from
agronomists the
natural resource conservation service i
asked them you know like can you
can you check which ones you turn to for
information
and on average the conventional farmers
selected more information sources
than the organic farmers although
there was greater variability within the
organic farmers
but more than the number of information
sources the type of information
differed so conventional farmers often
had more ties to add
professionals like agronomists and
nutritionists
and organic farmers we're more likely to
turn to
family members or grazing groups
when i when i look at the extent of
adoption
that farmers do i picked out three
different diversification practices the
first is pastures so a
field with multiple species
that animals go and graze on
um and so for organic farmers you can
see
uh more than half of them have around
half or more
of their land their farmed
land in pasture and like i said
there's a rule um for
organic certification that says you must
have pasture
and for conventional farmers about half
of them didn't have any
pasture at all now look at a second
practice
inner cropping perennials so planting
multiples
species together um mostly for stored
food
here it's alfalfa and cool citizen
grasses those are the most typical in
the area
and so organic farmers all of them had
around half or more of their acres
planted in inner crop perennials so
mixtures whereas about
half of the conventional farmers had
that
same amount of land you can think about
weed management
having those grasses in with alfalfa
really helps with weed management so if
you're organic
and you really are trying to manage your
weeds ecologically
then it makes sense why you would have a
mixture
and finally cover cropping
so we see here the tables have turned
and we see a lot more conventional
farmers having half
or more of their acres in cover crops
and this is because they do a lot more
well there's more animal production and
the farmers i spoke with were pretty
adamant
they said if they were harvesting corn
silage
they really strongly preferred to plant
a cover crop
after that corn silage came off
but of course you know weather gets in
the way so this
isn't always able to happen
and then for organic farmers you see
they have
uh less acres than annuals so there's
less of a
need to plant cover crops but also
you have this section of farmers that
have
no adoption these these are farmers that
don't have
any annual production whatsoever so they
they just don't do cover crops because
everything's in pasture
so i have to i asked the
organic farm i said you know when you're
making
a mix of the inner when you're
intercropping perennials what
how do you walk me through that mix like
what do you
put in how do you think about it he said
if i put
three kinds of alfalfa in there some
alfalfa does better in the heat
some does better in the wet the mix
might be doing well in the hot of the
summer
if we get a dry deer at least something
will grow
and it feels that's more bottomland
we'll get
more grass so this is really interesting
to me
because i'm hearing this farmer say he
plants
multiple varieties of the same species
looking for that response diversity
and that he adjusts the composition of
his mixture
to suit the land knowing that the
grasses can do better in wetter
areas
on the other side um i asked
can you i asked everybody what are your
motivations and barriers for doing this
and a conventional farmer told me he
said
the part with the grass is for us
right and we're talking about
inter-cropping perennials still
the part with the grass is for us we're
always planting
corn so the first cutting is always
variable
because we can't get to the grass as
fast that's in the alfalfa
because we're planting corn so here i'm
hearing that
animal crop reduction is prioritized
and that variance that i was talking
about
earlier is a burden to this farmer's
operation
because it it changes up the forage
quality
so when i think about farm types as
social ecological systems and go back to
this map
you know the conclusions i draw are that
the sociotechnical configuration
is much larger for the conventional
farmer and that
um they really try and control their
variability
that's on the field so this level is
minimized
whereas the opposite is true with the
organic farmers that they're
putting more of a focus on the fields
and there's less of an attachment
to a socio-technical configuration
so when i think about what this means
for
resilience you know your ability to
absorb stress
to adapt your flexibility i think about
it in three parts
i think about the kind of production
systems the farmers have
the kind of learning they do and the
amount of coordination
so in the production systems
conventional firms had more
annual production and they have less
temporal and spatial
variants but because
they were larger they could actually
choose like i choose to plant this in a
pure stand because i know
this field is ideal for peer stand so
they're getting rid of
variance at the field level but they
just have
they're like they're able to choose and
keep uh keep it and keep it at the
the farm level
when i think about learning for our
farmers where conventional and organic
farmers
are guided by different cognitive um
cognition and norms so conventional
farmers
really talked about high levels of
production
and they also
spoke a lot about you know this concept
feeding the world
i see that as like a world where to
um thing where we did have to feed the
world for some time but
perhaps perhaps it's in the past and
then
um organic farmers often talked about
understanding farms as an organism as
the whole thing together
and then that they were trying to mimic
nature and we see this because
um you know organic farmers synthesized
knowledge of the land
the land and the animals because the
animals were grazing
they were on the land so there was
that wholeness whereas conventional
farmers often synthesize knowledge
from specialists so they were really
trying to get that high production
and so they were coordinating with a lot
of experts
in the socio-technical configuration and
so
coordination you know organic
regulations something to keep in mind
other foreign regulations if you're a
larger firm kfo
access to markets so moving from who to
how
there's not enough information
for ecological based farming so perhaps
that's why that socio-technical
configuration is smaller for organic
farmers
they just it's just not information
that's
relevant to their kind of production
but it's important to keep in mind the
majority of farms
in this great nation are dependent uh
are conventional and they're dependent
on annual crop reduction so for the
the second half of this presentation i'm
going to work
to show the benefits of crop diversity
and and work to show how to
we could improve say cover crop mixtures
and thinking about cover crops is like
the gateway drug to crop diversification
the low
hanging fruit so
here i situate myself as an actor in
this
in this larger space and i'm working to
effect change in this
system and i'm focusing on ecosystem
services so for this experiment
this was an amazing experience
experiment so what we did was like crop
diversity
um we we wanted farmers
you know to have
to diversify right and so how would they
do that
how much diversity do you need what kind
of diversity do you need
and we tested out four different
strategies
of diversity in three crops and we
planted these crops in
in ithaca vermont and new hampshire
this was funded uh by one million dollar
grant from our yrie went from 2016 to
2019.
this was awesome it funded my
dissertation
and i think that it was such a great
experiment
we did a pretty simple design randomized
complete block
but large the plots were 30 by 50 feet
and what we did is these different
places a lot of different weather
different things going on we
we standardize what kind of yield goals
we're going for
and how we're going to sample but we
really
manage the fertility the different kinds
of management and when we would harvest
specific to the site
and so our hypotheses were that
treatments with greater
crop diversity will have higher
yields more stable yields lower
weed biomass higher forage
quality and a greater economic
performance
than treatments with lower diversity so
uh golden lasso coming in again a lot of
different indicators that we were
examining
so the diversity treatments the four
strategies that we picked out
varied in their amount of inter and
intra-specific diversity
so different species and also different
number of varieties and we're looking at
perennials
uh winter annuals and summer
annuals and these two things were in the
double crop
system so they were going on the same
space
so for the low treatment we just have
one
um one species one variety very simple
for that con specific you can see this
plus over here
stands for varieties we have four
different varieties so four different
alfalfa varieties really trying to see
you know like what does that response
diversity
give us um heterospecific so four
different species one variety each
and high so four species and four
varieties and so
across uh two or three
years depending on which crop it was we
took
18 harvests across the three sites for
the perennials
nine for winter annuals
and ten harvests for summer animals
and looking at yield stability of
perennials so this is the alfalfa
timothy orchard grass
clover uh and yield stability is like
how well does how well do these
strategies
do in different growing conditions
and the way we calculate this is we use
environmental mean which is just an
average of biomass across black site
year so all the treatments together
that we take a harvest what's the
average biomass
and then the y-axis is the
harvest for the yield for this specific
treatment so we can see the
the purple and the blue lines are
generally
higher than the other two lines so
heterospecific and high treatments
so these both contain inter-specific
diversity
and they perform better in all growing
conditions
for yield and yield stability
that's awesome let's add the other crops
in
so we have perennials i just showed you
this
and then we have winter annuals
and summer annuals and the winter
annuals are kind of forming a v
you can see the the blue and purple
is lines are doing better up here so
treatments with inner specific diversity
do better
in good growing conditions we attribute
this to adding
cereal or rye to the triticale
and then in summer annuals we see that
that uh the the inner specific
treatments do better in
poor growing conditions so when things
are not going well it pays to have
diversity
for the summer annuals
we also looked at found evidence of
temporal diversity in the perennial
mixtures within a growing season
so each line is
a different location
for the two different years and then
each column
is a different harvest that we took
within a year and after establishment
year
uh we see that percent alfalfa in their
perennial
mixtures so we've looked at these
mixtures
and then how much alfalfa there was
amidst
the other species the timothy orchard
grass and clover
and we saw that this uh first cutting
generally had a lower
uh percentage of alfalfa
compared to the the other harvest the
other cuts
um what we determined was that cool
season grasses do better in the spring
than alfalfa this is likely to
differences in growth initiation so
grasses go by photo period so just how
much
light is out there whereas alfalfa
growth is dependent on
heat units so what that temperature is
like
when we see alfalfa growth improves in
the summer
in part because it has this tap root so
if it does get dry it usually
can access moisture but the cool season
grasses
also get triggered into dormancy
uh with the heat so that's sometimes
called a summer slump so we see
um you know the composition of the
mixture
changes throughout the year so that's
pretty
i thought that was pretty cool um
and so just to summarize effects of
deployed diversity strategies
uh we saw the most differences uh
in their perennials and we saw more
differences with inner specific
diversity and so comparing the high
treatment to the lower treatment
perennials
had um the high treatment had 25 percent
more yield
uh weed biomass was in order of
magnitudes lower
and it had lower seed costs and and
grasses tend to be
cheaper than legumes um
which is an effect of the
socio-technical
system right if lithiums were
less expensive to plant probably more
people
would plant them um with winter animals
we saw the high treatment was 12
had 12 percent greater crop yield
compared to the low treatment
and in summer annuals weed biomass
was 36 percent lower in the high
compared to the low
this is really interesting this is like
money in the bank if you can
decrease your weed biomass not change
your yield just by adding some more
species
i would say that's not like i would be
very interested to do that
um but there were some
issues uh with the establishment
of the mixtures in the annuals we
planted some winter legumes they didn't
really show up
and then with the summer annuals there
were a couple of species that dominated
so this points to the need for more
precise eating rates
and i should say in this experiment
we're using
replacement rate design so for four
species
each species would um
was seated at a quarter at the rate that
it would be planted in monoculture
so more precise eating rates
so can we build better crop mixtures and
again
uh trying to improve this system really
looking at this level
down here so we came up with this
methodology
for constructing multi-functional
crop mixtures and the goal of this is
not like the premises if we can build
better mixtures
we're going to improve that cost benefit
ratio
if we improve the cost benefit ratio
farmers are probably going to be more
likely
to adopt it right it is it's less of a
burden and so we're
looking uh from multi-functional
mixtures we said
high production um so when you think
like
species have functions and perform
different functions
they have to be present to do it the
more they're present the more they would
be able to perform that function
but because we wanted
multi-functionality
we're looking at a high
level of evenness so do these species
show up in relatively similar quantities
if i plant three things
is it like a hundred grams a hundred
grams and a hundred grams
uh or is it 99 grams and then one gram
and one gram
so we want high production and also
high levels of evenness with low cost
right of course and so what we do
when you're selecting a mixture this is
the methodology you pick out
what you want to happen um you know what
functions
that is so high biomass that might be a
grass
nitrogen fixation that's a legume and
then you pick out species that perform
these functions
and the question is what kind of seeding
rates
do you use for these species to make
this multi-functional
mixture and so
to determine the the seeding rates we
are going to i grew the species in
monoculture
and also in biculture so like
the simplest mixture you can do just
with one other species
what i did was i quantified the
competitive ability
of these species and then
from there i used these competition
coefficients that i generated
to simulate the biomass of three and
four species measures so
more complex mixtures i identified you
know which ones
fit my criteria and then i made up some
rules about them
so for this experiment i chose four
species
two grasses pearl millet sorghum sea jam
grass
and two legumes so cow pee
and sun hemp and
then what i did next was i planted them
using a response surface design
and and this is just like a fancy word
for
a grid and i planted
eight uh eight different seating rates
for each of the monocultures and so you
can see
these are here on the axes
and so for sorghum seed and grass are
planted from 40 percent of the standard
seeding rate first organ
all the way to 120 of the
standard seeding rate and i did the same
thing for the second
species and the rest of the species of
course
but then i also planted eight different
rates
of the biculture um mixes
so uh
so i planted like twenty percent uh
and forty percent of the second species
so trying to fill out this grid
and from there we
we grew all these things we had six
different response surfaces
and we measured the biomass from them
and we
counted how many plants were out there
okay and so then i fit this
into a yield density model
and what this what this model allows us
to do
is we plug in yield here and then we
plug in the densities of one species say
millet
and also if present the
density of a second species say sorghum
sedan grass
and then we we use this general
framework to gen
and non-linear regression to
to get these competition coefficients
so this competition coefficient is the
measure
of intro specific competition so how
much
does one millet plant compete with it
with other millet plants now how much
competition does a millet plant
uh with sorghum sea dam grass so that's
the inter
specific competition you just like
to lay this out graphically this is the
yield density model
so you have density and you have yield
and the more you increase the density
the more you increase your yield but you
know
like the you know marginal effects
decrease for every increase of density
as you get up here
and so basically we're trying to
understand what do the shape of these
curves look like and when you add a
competitor
you can see if i increase the density of
sorghum to dam grass
then the pro the millet yield
will decrease
and it's like how how fast does it
decrease depends on
the competition coefficient here
so to determine the seeding rate for
mixtures
the next step is to simulate the biomass
of
the three and four species mixtures so
what i did was i
developed an equation that was very
similar to the one
i just showed you that
that uh you can just
add the competition coefficients that
you got from the bicultures
and use it to predict the biomass of
three species and four species mixtures
so we made up a lot of different
densities
and then we use this equation and
determined what the biomass was
and then after that um we
you know like we identified these
mixtures and we made some rules and i
already said that
so in this case we simulated 10
000 mixtures from the four species
within the range of densities that we
used to find the competition coefficient
this is just a testament to how big
these things can get like how fast they
can get so
we we plotted all of the mixtures that
we simulated
i need to draw it here represents a
mixture
we looked at the total biomass that's on
the x-axis
and the evenness which is on the y-axis
so evenness goes from zero to one
one is the most even so everything shows
up
in equal proportions
so on the left hand side i overlaid
um the seed cost of the mixture
so it's like very inexpensive over here
it's probably because it's really low
seating density
what we're looking at is like for this
magic and this
upper corner so to find these optimums
we used a pareto front analysis to
just find out you know what are these
outer limits and
it was mostly one uh mixture it was
millet
sorghum sedan grass and sun hemp
together so that was quite interesting
that was our ideal mix
so then to move forward and make up some
rules for that mix
um
basically so we determined that the
monoculture rate for these
different species uh you know
varies according to their competitive
ability so so we're going to see jam
grass
which is a big it's a big plant and it's
very
competitive that it's going to have a
lower seeding rate
when it's planted in this mixture if you
want even
biomass so um
these kinds of things this methodology
could be used in decision making tools
or by seed companies who are making
their own mixtures and
and want to make better mixtures i'm so
excited
um shout out to helen who's taking up
the mantle
of of this work and using this
methodology
in a a bunch of cover cropping
experiments across
the east so i just want to provide
some commentary on inner cropping
experiments
they are by virtue of like what they're
trying to do
they're complicated right you're adding
complexity to them
so what happens is that the findings of
inner cropping experiments
are often confounded by the experiment
designs themselves and
you know like how far into the
interpretation that you
what could be really useful is um
this this idea that we could work
towards understanding
species behavior in a growing condition
not confounded by the design
and i realized like that that's probably
a hard ass because these
designs are you know like replacement
rate designs they're
they're generally simpler to carry out
um
and so the research for these kinds of
experiments
i would say is is really not happening
fast enough
to gain traction within the
socio-technical system
to make these shifts and so like
i'm going to continue to pursue
these these questions and ideas and i
also proposed some some data standards
so at the very least if we can't
um you know get away from some of these
confounding effects at least we can
spell it out
in the papers and so when we synthesize
this information
we can somewhat parse it out
so i wonder i want to bring this like
all together
back to the big picture when you think
about adoption diffusion
a lot of the literature came out of
oh is that really technology transfer
oriented
um but it's still quite useful
um you know these criteria
they have for innovation so
i want to apply them to this social
ecological
system and say like if
if we're changing the socio-technical
system
you know this new technology or this
advancement
will need to be compatible within the
form
itself and it will be helpful
if you can trial it if farmers can trial
it
and also observe it so when you improve
the cost benefit ratio
perhaps those results become more
observable and they provide more
and better ecosystem services which then
provides farmers with a relative
advantage
compared to other um actors
and so to close you know just
from the beginning an increase in crop
diversity over time and space
increases the likelihood of farmland to
absorb stress
and provides flexibility for the farmer
to adapt
institutions and norms are not yet
configured for ecological based
management
or crop diversification practices on the
in the mainstream um i would point out
organic certification does seem to be a
good regulatory inroad
it does require you have a minimum
amount of crop complexity and that
you integrate animals onto the land
with pasture and so i challenge all of
us as
consumers to seek um
you know goods that espouse the
principles of
crop diversification um
efforts could be made in regards to the
organization coherence of intercropping
science so what i just indicated
to show the benefits of crop diversity a
holistic set of indicators
would be needed to understand
productivity right
yield in relation to other ecosystem
services so really thinking about
the cropping system as a whole
and then finally to reimagine
ag systems in the faces of challenges
posed by climate change it will be
important to develop
new ways to understand these systems
so that could be applied ecology
for making better mixtures
it could be qualitative mixed methods
for understanding diversification and
practices
and what farmers do and
you know finally it's the recognition
that even if we start with cover crop
mixtures
that's not the the end that's that's the
beginning
so um
really uh
i yeah acknowledgements i have
so much love for my family and my
friends
who have been so supportive along this
journey
um i can't say enough good things
about my committee um
you've really helped me incredibly to
develop these ideas
um lots of love to the
lab to the section of soil and craft
sciences
to the dairy farmers that i interviewed
and my
collaborators throughout the usda
university of vermont new hampshire and
in
france at inra so
with that thank you i yield my time
all right thanks ann nice job there so
um
we do have some time for questions um
so if there are a few questions if
you're happy to take those
um if you would just mute yourself and
and ask away that would
be um that would be preferred so i have
a question
hi anne great job really exciting
results this is brian brown
by the way um i'll be asking for some of
your slides to share
at some point um so
clarence swanton at the university of
galt of guelph
has shown that for some crops i think
he's mostly working with corn and
soybeans
just the mere sight of a weed
or a plant of another species
even if it's not competing with that
crop plant
just this kind of the site of it i guess
based on the
the light reflectance is enough to
stress that crop plant and cause a
reduction in yield
and i'm wondering if you saw any
evidence of that
in any of your mixtures
well i just want to say that crop sounds
really high strung
um in
in the in the mixtures there is
certainly a lot of
competition among species and so
um yeah like i don't
i i'm not sure about stress
the species that were out competed were
generally
smaller they weren't able
mostly with light competition that
that seemed to be the biggest factor
especially for the
annual mixtures
and so you know like sorghum cd and
grass and millet together that millet
tended
to be to be smaller but it would still
persist
and i'm happy to share those slides
awesome thanks great job anne
any other questions there
i have a question hey catherine
um i'm uh well i really
liked your um competition curves
for your um species mixtures
and i'm wondering um how your um
how the competition curves looked was
was it just with sorghum and
millet or was it with the two types it
was
it was with the four different species
so there's
12 in all combinations
and little combinations of those four
species
yeah okay so how did it look with the um
the was it it was two legumes and two
grasses yeah
so the legume legume versus legume
like the the kind of shape of those
competitive distributions depends on
which pairs of
species and how those looked yeah
you know we had a hypothesis that
different functional groups would be
more complementary that you would
you would get some benefit from having a
mixture of grasses and
legumes versus like a grass grass
flaking legume
but the biggest amount of competition
that we saw uh
was between the two the two grasses
uh with each other so sorghum sea dam
grass really
uh outcompeted pearl and millet
and then um so with the legume legumes
uh sun hemp was a stronger competitor
than calpe and so increasing the sunhem
density would decrease the the cowpeat
density
but it wasn't as stark as a difference
as
as we saw with the two grasses
in combination and then um
okay and how would you quantify a
competitive effect
in like your seeding rate like
if you add this number of seeds in a
monoculture you'll get this much more
biomass versus
like in a mixture you'll get you know
this much more
biomass and it's like um
do you like quantify that
biomass in a mixture i if i was
i'm gonna interpret your question and if
it's not the right question
then we'll start over um so if i was
thinking like how would i design
a cover crop calculator to incorporate
competition
coefficients then thinner with
um you know
the if it's a more competitive
species then you would want to reduce
the rate so there would be some
increment that you would want to reduce
the rate
if you were including these other
species if it
you know like was a a less competitive
species say a monoculture
it's probably going to be closer to them
the monoculture rate and then you're
just going to add
uh other species to it
yeah that's what i was asking cool
we are at 10 o'clock here so i think we
should hold off on other questions i'm
sure ann would be very happy to
follow up with anyone if i want to
contact her via email
but we have some other business to take
care of so
for committee members we will actually
be signing off of this zoom meeting and
going to a new
zoom meeting for the the question part
of the defense
everyone else thank you so much for for
joining us today this morning and i hope
you all
have a good rest of your day take care
great job man thank you everyone for
for coming
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu